I was going to ask you uh
you tell me the story on how you and
Alchemist met and how he became a part
of the Sol I met Al when he was like 13
I had this
manager um and they was like hey you
want to make a lot of money and I was
like well what you talking about we got
this little rap group two little white
kids from Beverly Hills and I was like
get that [__] the [__] out of here
dude was James conon yeah I didn't meet
him I didn't see him I was just like the
concept of that [__] was like what you
trying to do like a criss cross but a
white pain I was like so I think they
ended up bringing him to B real and B
real work with him but then I met Al and
I was like oh this kid is cool as [__]
he reminds me of me like just like just
tenacious [__] worker like worker and
just the love and the [__] and smart
and just work and work and work and just
on point I was like okay I'm going to
give this kid access and let him be
around and then like I'm going to just
cut cut all this [__] you have to go
through and just put you right here you
with the biggest group in the world now
in the studio going on tour hanging out
you know what I mean and just like give
him access cuz I knew all he needed to
do is be around it he's such a [__]
smart kid and such a sponge you'll
figure it out you know what I mean just
give him access to the [__] was it um
was he always wanting to step away from
rapping and just focus on producing when
I met him he didn't make beat [__] okay
and then when he did that first time
they was they wasn't they weren me he
was learning and he was really he was a
real Premier fan and and it was just
like you know some sea level Premier
like kid [__] and he was just I'll be
like no that's not it bro but you knew
like I always knew Al has that that
that's it that it thing that special
[__] thing like he's just [__]
whatever Al decided he wanted to do he
was going to be successful in it you
know what I mean he's just that smart
and that [__] that that much of a
hard worker and that got that much Focus
so you know we just brought him put him
under my wing it's like you know his he
starts see seeing how records albums are
made how Studio sessions are run you
know and the little tricks the little
behind the [__] going on tour with us
carrying the carrying the crates and
[__] you know what I mean you're on
[__] big Festival tours you know what
I mean at [__] 15 years old Le
leaving school yeah crazy and then
eventually you know now he's he's
Alchemist Grammy nominated God he's the
illst in the game right now man I I I
agree man I I was just saying like his
like last couple year run has been like
it's so crazy like think about the stuff
he's done with Baldi with Freddy like
he's just been just Relentless he hasn't
done nothing different he's been working
this hard all these years it just you
know it's just timing that it just it's
the perfect storm you know it's like the
the way the music is and the the way the
what we like the culture is growing and
then just the right artist at the right
times with all the momentum he's built
up over the years you know what I'm
saying I was going to ask you um your
production process how much has it
changed over the years cuz back in the
day everybody would have their go-to
equipment nowadays like I'll like know
guys who I never ever thought would
touch like a digital platform like who
will only be on Ableton or they'll only
be on prot tools like what is your I um
it was the same for me man I was using
the sp12 I moved over to the MPC and
then it just I wanted to do some
electronic [__] for fun and I was like
how do you do this [__] and like oh I
can't do it on this [__] I got to learn
this [__] computer and I was like I
was the last [__] bro to [__]
with the computer like you were hanging
on to the I was hanging on the 2in
everything and I was just like [__] it
so I just took a year and just worked on
some electronic music and just took a
year and just dialed just worked on the
machine until I figured out like oh I
can get my sound out of this thing
because it turned into a lot more um
sound designning and you know getting
into the [__] the the effects yeah
there's plugins for everything yeah yeah
and then having having not having to
have a big studio and learn everything
and [__] plugging everything in and
just having it right there my fingertips
I was like actually it started getting
fun again for me like super fun again
you know and then and then my my
daughter got to a certain age where I
was like oh I don't got to [__] be
there all the time so you know it was
like 6 years ago is when I was like oh
it's about me again now it's my time
kids are raised shit's all good all
right y'all I love everybody but it's my
time it's I'm I'm going to be greedy now
it's the most freest I've ever been dive
right back in and so I think we've done
like you know 34 35 projects in the last
six years